Vsauce! The Silkie is a breed of chicken whose
bones, flesh, and skin are a dark blueish
grey or black. While considered unusual in
European and American cuisines it's a gourmet
food in several Asian cuisines, including
silkie soup.... which is black chicken soup.
Huitlacoche or Corn Smut is a fungus that
grows on the above ground parts of the corn
species that is often used in Mexican cuisine
like quesadillas and other tortilla based
foods. The word huitlacoche has been translated
as Raven's Excrement and Corn Excrement.
Canard a la Rouennaise also known as Duck
in Blood Sauce is a traditional French dish
where a duck is partially roasted and put
into a specially designed press where the
blood and other juices are extracted and used
as a sauce - and it's considered the height
of elegance.
Alright now there's a food called Balut which
may be disturbing for some people so if you
really want to see it pause the video right
now and google it. So yeah... let's move on.
TUNA EYEBALLS!
Akutaq is Eskimo Ice Cream made out of whipped
animal fat, often seal fat, fish, and berries
that has been made for thousands of years
and it started as a special traveling food
for survival -and can also be made with Moose
meat.
Urechi unicinctus is a marine spoon worm eaten
raw with salt and sesame oil in Korea and
is referred to the fat innkeeper worm or.......
the penis fish.
Hasma is made from fried fatty tissue found
near the fallopian tubes of true frogs and
is a common dessert ingredient in China and
Central Asia. And it's sometimes referred
to as toad oil.
Bird's Nest Soup is made out of chicken broth
and the nests of the swiftlet, a bird found
throughout SE Asia that makes its nests out
of it's own gummy saliva that hardens when
exposed to air. Harvesting the nests is dangerous
and makes the soup a delicacy. A kilogram
of white nest can cost up to $2,000 and a
kilogram of red nest can cost up to $10,000.
Pig's Blood Cake is a popular dessert in Japan
where pig's blood is combined with sticky
rice and rolled in peanuts and cilantro....
and then served on a stick where you then
dip them in different chili sauces.
Escamole are the eggs of the Liometopum ant
and are often called "insect caviar." It has
a cottage cheese-like consistency and it's
commonly eaten with guacamole and in tacos.
But harvesting the eggs can be unpleasant
as the ants are venomous and don't like humans.
Finally after all those mouth watering foods
wash it down with some rice wine, full of
baby mice. Which is considered a health tonic
and supposedly tastes like gasoline.
While I was researching this episode i came
across a youtube show called Why Would You
Eat That on the channel Tasted. So check that
out if you're interested in more of these
foods - stay tuned for more food focused videos
in the future right here on Vsauce2 and as
always - thanks for watching.